ضجه شهدتها مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في
الايام الاخيره بعد واقعه هجوم كلب من
فصيله بيتبول على رجل في احدى التجمعات
السكنيه الراقيه ما احدث به اصابات بالغه
في الاوتار والاعصاب ادى الى دخول في
غيبوبه حتى اليوم
قصه بدات عندما كان الاب عائدا الى بيته
مع ابنه ومعه مشتريات فوجد كلب جيرانه في
الحديقه خلف صور صغير توجه بعدها لشقت
الجار للتاكيد له على السيطره على الكلب
وفور فتح الباب هاجم الكلب الرجل ممزقا
اوتارا واعصابا في القدم واليد ما استدعى
خضوعه لجراحه دقيقه
واثناء الجراحه توقف قلب الرجل لمده نصف
ساعه ثم عاد ينبض من جديد ولكنه دخل في
غيبوبه تامه تم القبض على صاحب الكلب الذي
لم يكن هو وزوجته موجودين في البيت اثناء
الحادث كما تم ايداع الكلب بمستشفى
البيطري حيث قال احد شهود العيان انه سبق
وعاقر احد الجيران
هذه الواقعه اثارت قضيه امتلاك الكلاب
والقوانين المنظمه لهذا الامر كما تقدمت
النائبه امال عبد الحميد بمقترح للبرلمان
بمنع استيراد كلاب من فصيله بيتبول
هذا الحادث فتح ملف اقتناء الكلاب وخاصه
في الاحياء الراقيه التي يحب اصحابها
استيراد كلاب من نوعيات غير مالوفه كما
اثارت الجدل مره اخرى حول قضيه كلاب
الشوارع التي تسبب مخاوف للعديد من السكان
من ناحيه او ما يتعلق بالتوازن البيئي من
ناحيه اخرى سمر بشات لصباح العربيه من
القاهره
[موسيقى]